how can Jesus give them the same Glory
that he had when this is the glory that
belongs only to God gee I've never heard
that one is that the question yeah
because in Isaiah gee I've never heard
that one uh Jesus is going to give them
the same Glory the father gave Jesus and
how can that be because you don't there
that's the glory of God you can't give
it to a creature it's all for J right
see how do I know you're gonna ask me
that question I don't know are you am I
scaring you're like man this dude is a
prophet he can read my Minds
right you probably like deal with it
exactly because I've heard this question
50 million times that's right so here's
the
question how could Jesus say the glory
you gave me father I gave to them I gave
to them the glory you gave to me when
that's a glory that belongs to God alone
well very easy yeah who told you that
there's only one type of
Glory that Jesus is referring to who
told you only one kind of Glory let me
tell you that the glory that Jesus is
giving them is not the glory that
belongs to God alone let me prove that
to you are you ready yeah okay go to
John 17 verse5 John 17 verse5
yes and now oh Father glorify thou thou
me with with thine own self with the
glory which I had with thee before the
world was can I ask you a
question yeah was there any discip
dwelling with God the Father before the
creation of the world sharing in the
same Glory that the father had before
the world was
created no no creature so number one
Jesus shows you the kind of Glory he
shares with the father is a glory that
no creature shares with the father
because no creature human
creature Earthly creature was there with
the father in the same Glory before the
world was created
right yeah that's number one right
right yeah okay now reread it one more
time and now oh Father glorify thou thou
me with thine own self with the glory
which I had with thee before the world
was okay so pay attention this is the
glory that Jesus had before the world
was created and the glory he shared with
the father now go to John
17:24 John 1724 okay father I will that
they also whom thou has given me be with
me where I am that they may behold my
glory which thou
has has given me for thou loved me
before the foundation of the world okay
we we read it one more time John
17:24 father I will that they also whom
thou has given me be with me where where
I am that they may behold my glory which
thou H has given me for thou love me
before the foundation of the world okay
are you seeing the connection with verse
five it he says you love me before the
foundation of the world and I want them
to see the glory you gave me because you
love me before the foundation of the
world so this glory is the same Glory
that he mentioned in verse five
right yeah right are you making the
connection everyone else Jesus says in
John 17:24 father I will that they also
whom thou has given me be with me where
I am that they may behold my glory which
thou Hast given me for you love me
before the foundation of the world that
directly ties him with John 175 and now
father glorify me together with thine
own self with the glory I had with you
before the world was so you see John
1724 and John 175 it's referring to the
same Glory that Jesus had with the
father before the world was created and
before the world was created the father
was loving the son right yes okay but
you didn't read John 17:24 carefully
guys pay attention so you learn John
1724 one more time read it father I will
that they also whom thou has given me be
with me where I am that they may behold
my glory which thou has given me for
thou loves me before the foundation of
the world did you catch it they will
only Behold The Glory that Jesus had
with the father they won't share in
it oh okay see see now the light switch
went on right yeah yeah now father I
want those that you have given me to be
with me where I am where I am to
see my
glory the glory you gave me notice
they'll behold That Glory but they don't
share in that
Glory
yeah did you catch it yes they they
behold it they don't like possess it
that's the glory Jesus had with the
father before the world was created
which the father will then give back to
the son because he loves the son and has
been loving the son from before the
world which the disciples will see but
not share
in right yes so then what is the glory
that Jesus does give to the disciples
which is not the glory that only God
possesses which Jesus possesses because
he is God a glory that he possessed
before the world was created with the
father what is the glory is talking
about are you
ready yes okay now go to John 17:22
again okay one more and the glory which
thou has givest me I have given them
that they may be one even as we are one
okay so to understand what Glory Jesus
is referring to read from John
17 verse 18 but we're going to read 17
to 20 so read John 17 the verse is 18
but read 17 to 20 John 17 17-2
sanctify them through my truth they word
is word Z word sanctify them through thy
truth Thy word is truth go ahead as thou
has sent me into the world even so I
have also sent them into the world okay
pay attention like you sent me in the
world I'm going to send them into the
world keep that in
mind so what is God Jesus praying set
them apart by your truth so that now
they will be ready to be sent out into
the World by your
truth to do what keep
reading and and for these sakes I
sanctify myself that they also might be
Sanctified through the
truth and 20 neither I pray for these
alone but for them also which Shall
Believe on me through their word okay
you make the connection with 18 to 20
father like you set me apart and sent me
into the world I will send them in the
world to do what I'm sending them into
the world so that through their
preaching through the word they'll
preach many will believe on
me you catching that so far as I walk
you through this so notice Jesus saying
like the father sent me in the world to
preach the gospel to get people saved I
now will send them into the world to do
the same to do likewise preach the
gospel and through their preaching
people will believe
right yes okay so you know what Glory
Jesus is saying that he's giving
them the glory that he manifested on
Earth through his ministry of Miracles
that's the
glory okay let me show you go to John 14
read 12-
14 The Glory that he's giving them is
the Glory Jesus revealed on Earth
through his ministry his ministry of
Miracles which now they will
do he said John 14 verse 12- 14 read
slowly John 14 12-
14 verily verily I say unto you he that
believes on me the works that I do shall
he do also and Greater Works than these
shall he do because I go on to my father
and whatever so ye shall ask in my name
that will I do so Jesus when he goes to
the father when Jesus goes to the father
he will then Empower them when he's with
the father to do greater Miracles
meaning more miracles than he did so but
who'll do it Jesus when he goes to the
father and they ask in his name I will
do what you ask in my name right keep
going yes it says if if he shall ask
anything in my name I will do it read 13
again and what so whatsoever ye shall
ask in my name that will I do that the
father may be glorified in the son
glorified there's the
glory yeah right I will give them the
glory you gave me the glory that I
manifested on Earth by the ministry of
Miracles which bore witness that the
father and the son are one and so now
that Glory of ministry where the
disciples will do Miracles by the power
of Jesus which will then bring glory to
the father and son through them that's
the glory he's giving them right yes so
let me show you that the glory that
Jesus is giving them is the glory that
he manifested on Earth which now they
will manifest through the ministry they
do the ministry that Jesus began but now
we'll continue through them okay now go
to John 11 when Jesus turned water into
the wine the first miracle John 21 what
does that say this beginning of of
miracles did Jesus in in Cana of of
Galilee and manifested forth his glory
and his
disciples disciples believed on him okay
wait read it again John 21 one more time
this beginning of miracles did Jesus in
Cana of Galilee and manifested forth his
glory and his disciples believed on him
so Jesus already had a glory on earth
right other than the glory that the
father gave back to him right yes so you
everyone's seeing there's different
types of glories Jesus already had a
glory on Earth but the glory that he had
with the father that he didn't have
while he was on Earth he set it aside
and he got it back again when he went to
the
father
right oh okay so it's a different Glory
basically you're not now it's sink in
well what do you think J do not say in
John 17:5 and now father glorify me
together with yourself with the glory I
had with you before the world was
meaning he didn't have when he's on
earth right yeah and then John 17:24
that's the glory that the disciples will
see but will not share in
right yes but wait it says he already
had a glory on
Earth that's a different Glory yeah what
Glory did he have on Earth the glory
glory of the Miracles the Miracles that
he did the physical Miracles was a type
of Glory that revealed who Jesus truly
was right yes now go to John 11 verses 1
and4 again this is now the miracle of
lazarus's Resurrection John 11 verses 1
and4 pay attention to verse four okay
now a certain man was sick named Lazarus
of Bethany the town of of Mary and and
her sister Martha it was that Mary which
anointed the Lord with ointment and and
DPed his feet with for her sister
sent unto him say saying Lord behold he
whom thou lovest is sick when Jesus
heard that he said this sickness is not
onto death but for the glory of God that
the Son of God might be glorified
thereby therapy thereby what see you
said therapy right so you're saying I
need therapy huh oh therapy huh hint
hint Sam you need therapy okay anyway
what did Jesus say in verse four read it
one more
time verse four when Jesus heard that he
said the sickness is not unto death but
for the glory of God that the Son of God
might be glorified thereby did you see
the miracle of Lazarus Resurrection is a
Glory that Jesus is manifesting on earth
right yes it's the Miracles right okay
so did Jesus have a glory on
Earth yeah he had a glory on Earth and
that Glory was connected to what the
glory with the Miracles and what is the
glory that Jesus is going to give to the
disciples the glory of the Miracles that
that he's doing so they're going to do
behold it and how do we know because if
you read from John 1718 to 22 you're
going to see like you sent me into the
world I send them in the world and all
will believe through their words so
that's what he's talking about that's
the glory you gave me I gave them to
carry on that glorious work on Earth so
by the part of the Miracles that will
bring witness and confirmation that you
father and I are
one right yes now John 11 same chapter
verses 11- 14
1114 okay almost done these things said
he and and the father that he said unto
them our friend Lazarus sleepeth but I
go that I may awaken him out of sleep
then said his disciples Lord if he sleep
he shall do well see just like you and
me are slow and getting stuff they were
slow too right
yeah see so you're in good company the
disciples are slow like you're slow and
I'm slow so see it's okay right see
Jesus saying he's asleep so okay he's
asleep he'll wake up why are we going to
travel two days to go wake him up come
on
what now if it was me and they said that
to me after I saying that I'd be looking
at one of the rocks and one of those
rocks I would have to name Timmy
Timmy you're my Timmy but anyway go
ahead read it keep reading so then what
did Jesus say
okay how how how the okay how about
Jesus speak of his death but they that
thought that he had spoken of taken of
rest and sleep then Jesus said unto them
plainly Lazarus is is dead
yeah I'm about to die by by the time you
finish this verse because it takes like
five hours I'm about to die too bro and
it ain't going to be sleeping keep going
dude I said all the way to 14 you know
I'm about to die in your hands right and
the problem is you can't resurrect
me and wait I I just heard 14 okay then
read it again because the way you're
reading I don't know where you're at
anymore you're killing
me
okay one more time bro we're both you're
killing me I'm killing you slow simmer
dude go ahead
read 14 again
14 then said Jesus unto them plainly
Lazarus is dead Okay so he had to
explain it because they were super slow
like you and me
right yeah and but so there's hope that
means if they were slow right and yet
still right and yet still by the grace
of God God transformed them and used
them mightily There's Hope for you and
me but just do me a favor make sure by
the time this is done you don't kill me
dead because it ain't sleep I'm not
going to go to sleep you're going to put
me to death because I don't think you
can resurrect me now with that said read
John
11:39 John
11:39 okay Jesus said take ye away the
stone Martha the sister of of him that
was dead say unto him Lord by this time
he stinketh for he hath been dead four
days now look how slow she is Jesus just
said your brother will rise and what is
she thinking oh but his body is DEC
composing his body is sth it's sth we're
gonna puke see There's Hope for you and
me she's slow too you didn't get it
right yeah now read John 11:40 what's
his answer Jesus Jesus says unto hers
said I not unto thee that if
thou what US believe those uh wait okay
I just lost it yeah it's okay CU you're
laughing at me because I'm just the
clown in your town that's why you stick
around all right go ahead read it again
Jesus said unto her said I not unto thee
that if thou wouldest believe though
should us see the glory of God thou
should us see the glory of God did you
see the glory again
yeah okay are you connecting it they saw
the glory of God through the
resurrection right yeah okay so what's
the
point Jesus gives the disciples one type
of Glory that Jesus manifested on Earth
but there's another type of Glory that
Jesus shares with the father before the
world was created that's not given to
any creature and not given to disciples
That Glory that Jesus shared with the
father before the world was is a glory
that the disciples will see but will not
possess okay is it making sense now yes
now I want you to walk away happy you
know I want you to walk away
happy right because you're not the only
slow Christian that ever existed the
disciples were so slow they go hey he's
asleep well hey Lord if he's asleep why
are we going to walk all these miles to
go wake him up his sister wake him up oh
my goodness are you serious
Lazarus is dead oh oh oh then Jesus
tells Martha your brother shall rise
again I'm the Resurrection Life he who
believes in me though he were dead yet
shall he live and he who believes in
live shall never die do you believe this
and she goes yes Lord I believe you are
the Christ the son of God he was to come
into the world that's John 11:23 to 27
they get to the stone move the stone
Lord he's been dead for days he
thanketh if you you remove the stone
it's going to be putrid and the smell we
going to puke just going to
[Music]
puke see so there's hope for you and me
man right yeah okay so did you get your
answer now yeah all right so I just want
you to know you
thanth
okay all
right everyone good what happen you went
silent what are you still laughing
you're laughing so hard that you can't
even say something